im mittelmeerraum brennen die welt als
eigentlicher zum ersten mal mit dem
wohnmobil durch italien fahren zu sehen
wie das so ist und wie teuer das wird
das ist
nicht aber gehen wir zwei wochen in der
zeit zurück als unsere einzige sorge war
was nehmen wir mit in den urlaub welche
ausrüstung braucht man eigentlich zum
campen mückenspray
für die sonnencreme und
so sieht die checkliste aus klamotten
hygieneprodukte handtücher schuhe
regenjacken regenschirm handys power
bankdokumente das übliche eben und
natürlich kamera equipment für dieses
video kamera akkus mikrofone
speicherkarten stativ eine drohne auch
aber vor allem eine 360 grad kamera die
in 36 die onex to und zweimal die super
winzige action kempinski 62 eine
philosophie und eine für mich sowie
einiges an zubehör dieses paket hat mir
das bonsai dieses videos und hersteller
der kameras eben in six die zur
verfügung gestellt damit sich unser
abenteuer für euch dokumentieren kann
und nicht immer meine schwere kamera
mitschleppen muss hier mit wurden also
fast alle aufnahmen dieser reisegefährt
einen link zu beiden produkten findet
ihr unten in der video beschreibung ich
glaub ich hab doch erstmal man eben
einfach nicht vergessen im urlaub stimmt
gar nicht unsere liste war einfach stark
die koffer sind gepackt und für einen
pflanzen babysitter wurde gesorgt es
kann losgehen zu unserem wohnmobil dass
uns die firma in mannheim ausgeliehen
hat wir sind jetzt da wir können und
setzen ein schönes wohnmobil als erster
überhaupt ich war gespannt also ich habe
ein bisschen angst damit dann
losgefahren aber ganz denn überhaupt
finanziert von italien und dann haben
wir mehrere stopps als wir machen
eigentlich was wir wollen erfahren warum
ich hatte noch nie von innen gesehen wie
fandest du hast zwar kann sich das ein
bisschen durchzuführen zu erkunden wo
kann man einige sachen verstauen was
gibt es eigentlich für gadgets
kühlschrank mit einer toilette dusche
den duschkopf konnte man sogar ausziehen
durch ein fenster nach draußen duschen
wenn man wollte die größten sorgen warnt
ein formales und bluetooth was wir
gesehen haben dass das
fliegengitter die waren wichtig das ist
es also das haus mit vier rädern in dem
wir die nächsten zwölf tage erleben
werden und die metapher mit dem haus
trifft bei einigen der luxusmodelle die
um uns herum stehen auch preislich auf
jeden fall zu unseres ist da ein gutes
stück bodenständiger und für zwölf tage
in der hochsaison juli august zahlt man
dafür circa 1600 euro also 800 euro pro
person in unserem fall ohne
kilometerbegrenzung ja und das haben wir
dann auch ausgenutzt was glaubst du wie
viel geld insgesamt für sprit
ausgegangen ist
bin mal gespannt wie das am ende mit
zusammen rennen
dann geht es jetzt los
mit sechs meter länge 28 breite und über
zwei meter höhe beginnt nun das
abenteuer so was großes bin ich noch
nicht annähernd gefahren
durch und mit meiner neuen 360 grad
kamera von intertek sieht man dass auch
fand hier im winkl wenn ich mich
blamiert ab jetzt leben wir zwei wochen
wo wir wollen mal schauen wo es uns hin
verschlägt als erstes ohne umwege in die
schweiz richtung luzern
[Musik]
als wir vor jedem urlaub natürlich
manchmal aufgeregt habe ich mich gefreut
als ein bisschen die welt erkunden gehen
kann erst am 200 dritten tag habe ich so
richtig realisiert dass man einfach
wirklich da blicken kann was man will
wir konnten tun und lassen was wir
wollen und das erste was ich gemacht
habe jetzt neben zürich einfach zu
warten und daneben
ist ja nicht so dass
gehört thomas fuchs das kann halt nur
wie ein fuchs klingen sollte also das
war halt nicht hin
dann wäre das rätsel auch gelungen
in der schweiz ist es grundsätzlich
übrigens nicht mal unbedingt verboten
einfach so weg zu kämpfen im kanton
zürich ist es zb für eine nacht im wald
sogar erlaubt also ich hatte trotzdem
man das gefühl dass wir irgendwas machen
dass dann jedes mal so schön erwischt
werden
[Musik]
nichts geht über einen spaziergang am
morgen zusammen mit unserem hündchen der
mai durch wunderschöne natur aber wenn
man sich diese aufnahmen also ansieht
ist man sich gar nicht mehr so sicher ob
die mine nicht doch vielleicht
eigentlich eine kuh ist
als
[Musik]
rennfahrzeug
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nein
so fiel die erste fahrt war noch recht
stark ersten 20 sekunden waren horror
van der vaart und dann würde ich
eigentlich relativ schnell entspannt
angehen 20 vollkommen in ordnung
wirklich gemacht hat sondern tatsächlich
nur weil wir ja mal binnen einer steilen
berg kurve vielleicht
diesen stecken geblieben aber es war
letztendlich nur so werden wir einen
bordstein heruntergefahren und das
wohnmobil hat überhaupt kein schaden
genommen unsere psyche ich glaube ich
schon am zweiten tag sind wir also
ausgehend von der umgebung zürich
richtung luzern vorbei an malerischen
vierwaldstätter see gefahren und haben
hier gemütlich gegessen mit traumhaften
ausblick endstation ist der luganer see
durch den die schweizerisch italienische
grenze verläuft und wo wir nun unsere
erste nacht auf italienischem boden auf
einem campingplatz verbringen die erst
danach trafen campingplatz war für mich
ein bisschen gemischte gefühle
aufgebracht und zwar einmal fand ich's
halt gut weil ich mich zum anfang
einfach noch ein bisschen unsicher
gefühlt habe als wir draußen irgendwo
geparkt haben und einfach da geschaffen
haben auf der anderen seite man halt
über all die ganzen menschen ja und
dieses kinderprogramm da lief ein
blick bis zum 10 8 sein woche oder
ähnlich das war ich lang ja ganze
campingplatz ist verregnet gefühlt und
das hat auch gewittert wie sonst was
davon verbrachte worden als sie an grass
werdenberg zerbrochen
der vorteil ist halten wir können uns
einfach diesen dahin wo die sonne
scheint dass man als auch aber diese
absolute freiheit mobil zu wohnen hat
natürlich auch seinen preis darf ich
vorstellen die chemie toilette und die
will natürlich auch entleert werden was
sagt uns nur seine kern situation man
kommt so auf jeden fall klar wenn man es
ist eine berufung war wie ich durch
einen teil eine nacht mit camper für
zwei personen und hund macht an der
rezeption des campingplatzes den wir
gerade verlassen übrigens 43 euro und
damit geht's weiter auf die strasse auf
die mautstraße um genau zu sein denn das
fahren auf guten autobahn geht
hierzulande dank dieser zettel die man
an mautstationen ziehen und bezahlen
muss echt ins geld aber natürlich ist
auch der sprit nicht gerade billig
einmal volltanken mit 70 litern diesel
kostet bei circa 190 pro liter ganze 130
euro wie hoch sich das alles summieren
wird wird man wohl erst am ende wissen
wir lernen uns schutzgebiet parker
nationale de la pena dosco emiliana
italienisch ist eine wunderschöne
sprache fast so wunderschön wie der
sternenhimmel unter dem wir uns noch
satz von pizza und pasta nun für unsere
erste kleine wanderung ausruhen
fehlt übrigens wieder mit der interviews
xd onex tun die 360 grad kamera die ich
hier wieder an einem drei meter langen
stab befestigt habe hält atemberaubend
fest wie es sich anfühlt in einem 100
meter tiefen abgrund zu stehen
[Musik]
jetzt folgen einfach nur gerade diesen
markierungen da aber wir vertrauen jetzt
einmal auf diesen wanderweg dingsda
selbst gleich bei den meisten see
ankommen werden wo wir uns schon auf
kumpels
schwimmen also gut ich dachte erst dass
diese erste wanderung an für anfänger
ein schild da stand drauf los experten
das war unter galopp tisch
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja
[Applaus]
mit den stars in bran xto und vor allem
der kleinen goto hier kann ich auch zum
ersten mal eine reise richtig cool
filmisch dokumentieren ohne dass sich
das nach arbeit anfühlt und man immer
warten muss alles richtig einzustellen
mit den zahlreichen
befestigungsmöglichkeiten der winzigen
guide to be here zum beispiel per
magnetische halskette unter meinem
t-shirt befestigt ist bremst diese auch
einfach per knopfdruck und auch nicht
das was ich sehe und ich habe trotzdem
meine hände frei fürs wesentliche
[Musik]
ob man es glaubt oder nicht aber einer
meiner weiteren highlights war der
campingplatz der wald aber der war ultra
schäbig also ich hatte komplett schiss
ein paar am tag davor soll ausgenommen
zu werden was halt richtig leute gegen
wir sind angekommen und dann hat es teil
direkt und tut dem parkplatz gelotst der
typ als ich gesehen habe war mir direkt
klar auf die uns wird keiner aus raum
auf dem platz mal derart uns mitträgt
und alles was sonst an minuten gebracht
hat was eh vorbei um uns vor allem nicht
nur die nudeln er hat es auch toll ich
will ohne gefragt und ein kühles wasser
ja
ja die pasta von unserem campingplatz
nachbar war aber nicht die einzige
kulinarische besonderheit lieder so
erleben durften sie haben eine der
besten schützen der welt gegessen
da war die beste pizza wert der beute
und nicht nur für uns das ist einer der
besten völker der welt also auf die
pelle das schon echt beinen sondern 6100
euro was haben wir ja schade war als das
auf dem vesuv man tickets zahlen aber
das was der umwelt kein netz gar keinen
fall und man konnte sich das ticket nur
online bestellen und generell ein ticket
für den berg gegen die national
wahrzeichen jetzt aber quatsch diese
erste erfolge
was haben wir uns eigentlich gedacht es
hat einen schon ein bisschen gegruselt
ja aber es war allerdings so weit weg
und man sieht der feier nicht man sieht
nur den rauch und irgendwie ja so es
hätte eigentlich mehr angst machen
sollen aber da was da noch auf den zug
gekommen ist das hätte ich jetzt nicht
so gedacht das war schon echt heftig
trotzdem sind wir dann aber noch die
stadt mathura einer der wunderschönsten
städte die ich jemals gesehen habe und
einer der romantischsten definitiv wir
sind genau im sommer begann da gewesen
und dann würde das nach zwei 1 fahrer so
wunderschön wirklich der plan dass wir
an der ostküste entlang fahren aber
man muss auch sagen dass diese feier bei
nacht definitiv tag da hatten den rauch
im auto das war richtig klasse sind
überall feuerwehrlöschfahrzeugen düst
einmal eine straße scheinbar abgesperrt
und das haben sie ja ausscheidung stehen
jetzt einfach darum um uns herum brennt
irgendwie alles ab war echt gruselig
weil jedes mal wenn man irgendwo ein
licht in der ferne gesehen habe mir das
mal gedacht das ist direkt die feuerwehr
mit wasser und die stadt aber trotzdem
hat jedoch richtig schiss gehabt das ist
wieder feuer war offenbar das heftigste
mit abstand war in einer phase gedacht
das ist wieder ein bisschen beruhigt hat
ja recht von uns weisen hotel und das
hotel war kurz davor in flammen auf da
war dann wollen wir dann eben die
einfach komplett gebrannt haben also
nicht nur so felder die überall waren
aber die bäume die 45 meter hoch
gebrannt haben uns die ganze zeit weil
auch diese aufgabe auch du hast ja kein
bock auf der rauchvergiftung und das war
halt schon also ein bisschen schwindelig
wurde einem da schon und selbst tag in
italien anschließend ging es dann
vielleicht bin ich stolz und da hat man
noch mal schön gewandert
[Musik]
warum ist auf jeden fall ins schon geil
also für mich geht's
europa ist megaschön und dann war
immerhin fahren zu können zu kennen und
halt komplett ungestört seine natur wo
man teilweise einmal gar kein netz halt
beim wandern das schon geil kostenmäßig
sind wir am ende pro person gerechnet
bei 800 euro fürs wohnmobil und 63 eur
50 für drei nächte campingplatz
insgesamt kommen wir auf sagenhafte 750
euro für sprit das ist aber für die
etwas übertriebenen viereinhalbtausend
kilometer die wir gefahren sind komplett
normal maut mussten der ganze 18 mal
zahlen und kam insgesamt auf 114 euro
zuzüglich einer vignette für die schweiz
alles in allem also
1314 euro pro person für zwölf tage
urlaub gegessen haben wir nichts teurer
als zu hause das fließt also nicht mit
in die reisekosten mit ein die beiden
klein und die 360 grad kamera ein
abenteuer damit der film war richtig
cool hat echt spaß gemacht für mich war
das komplett neu er hat voll geil die
links zu installation findet ihr
natürlich eine video beschreibung und
auf meinem zweiten kanal gibt jetzt den
ganzen review zu diesen dingen wo ich
das mal so ein bisschen an boxer und
auch so ein bisschen zeigt wie man damit
videos bearbeitet und so fort wie das
alles funktioniert also texas gerne mal
ab und dann würde ich sagen sehen wir
uns beim nächsten mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]